hello and welcome to this video playing
root reader Hut wow talk about a root
Hut hmm okay so let's see how Kings
Indian or green felt what do we get a
green felt okay
you know c6 that sir the solid line
unless they take and play C 5 and it's
not so solid okay
b5 is 7 this is now a very common place
in okay
usually this is a strategic mistake to
play 97 because now the C file is
getting opened up and you really want a
knight on c6 in such a situation
now b5 is going to be a problem so bit
surprised them okay no let's play
immediately for Bishop c7
seven depends
it's very quick maybe he can actually
play Bishop d7 and disposition
as it is a counter check on my monoid
yeah yeah maybe I should have thought
about this a little bit I was a bit bit
of a quick decision
you
no Bishop d7 looks right
that was Simmons not great actually
I mean not in trouble or anything but
that was not the best way of playing
but it's made him think made him pause
I'm not certain at all what he should
know we should be somnium that's what I
am expected
good cover this
I think Bishop c7 just leads to trades
and nothing okay well this is nice form
which now is kind of tight you know the
Queen has to cover the night the night
cannot move because b7 faults and if I
play rook c1 next what is the reply
there's bishops is seven on the way
that's pretty awful really
yeah that makes some sense that makes
some sense
to get rich
get rid of the bishop
I can't just play hook see one it's
going to be a lot better forward
then double him that's I keep it simple
you know
see defending against rook c5 Roxy 1
muxes 7
it's not easy
No very difficult to find something
there okay Brooke c5 or is there
anything better no I don't think so
it will probably take one be three
I want to take with the paw and keep a
fo and C for control
night shouldn't be able to go to see for
now groups is seven
what's your reply he too is not hanging
books is seven nights II for maybe but I
can grab
which relates you for
Queen Queen Toby Sam no
you
now just this one how is the night ever
moving that is a really sad piece on aid
I always have this covered who the queen
is covering it ooh
yeah if
thing so f4 is a tech but
I could just do this
it's increment I'm not
in on time
so how do we how do we prevent any sort
of counterplay
the the main thing is the knight should
move
is there thread not really
I can get rid of this rook I'm just
winning
maybe this one for Luke a one that looks
good actually
Oh the debt is okay that's the only act
of peace but maybe I got something
better
[Music]
thinking is completely completely fine I
mean now Queen a one maybe
keep the keep the night under fire oh
well we'll look dad he's got this
you
huh I mean it's not like the night is
very strong still not but
amid a bit of a bit of a mess
you
I'm very uh near people
play here that was absolutely terrible
really
from where from a completely completely
winning position to this one
which is better for Wyatt still but it's
not comparable at all I mean he was that
was almost reasonable what he had
I'm not saying that you should have
resigned you I'm just saying it was very
bad
yeah this is not going to
easy
you
you
[Music]
yeah not at all
no that was probably not a good idea
we have 3:45 the others should be simply
pretty easy when
[Music]
now I can take
you
you
now it was pretty awful actually
I didn't convert this pollution well
yeah this this was this is some
interesting so 97 is a bad move earlier
because of the caption so we should f4
96 and I'm really not that much
with an IP five with hindsight because
Bishop d7 is a reasonable defense but
you shouldn't take taking as a pretty
awful mistake I mean that that leads to
a position where I don't really see how
he defends anymore because this Bishop
this one what I played back basically
it's just it's just terrible Bishop d2
is even stronger them but you know this
is pretty pretty bad as well why is I
said okay
- 0.1 yeah haha okay stock wish needs
some chess lessons
why is that supposed to be its that's
completely complete nonsense okay zero
point one is not really better but
anyway so what is the thing this this it
now is just so it's just about right to
get dissing okay okay this is an
ingenious defense okay and equal so this
is why this is not so great actually
as good as I thought this is just the
only thing that works would be 86 Lucas
7 which he didn't find in the game he
was a bit too slow okay
yeah well it's clear that this was
stronger anyway I'm threatening this
this is this is actually over this is
something like that you're not going to
save this okay yeah so after inform it
was I said okay for like are you crazy
nights eight
you
so black simply sacrifices a pong yeah
okay and the engine thinks this is okay
rook c8 and you cannot convert it okay
okay interesting okay so they are great
defensive ideas it's very it's not very
human but and again this worked okay I
thought this one has the same idea
the engine just gives up the pawn and
says it's okay
okay okay night aid and don't know
finally I'm clearly better okay
I didn't convert this I mean this was
fine and now I have to improve I mean
okay Knight age four is probably better
but still I mean does this looks like it
should be should be winning but now he
gets 97 and it's not so simple
eh okay
hmm
yeah but now I mean here's a very decent
counterplay
Queen d1 was to draw him which he should
probably play
87 and then Roxy 801 yeah obviously miss
many things and here
Queen eight keeps the porn covered yeah
now I'm better but I probably shouldn't
necessarily win the game I think you
just has to avoid the Queen's red
you
you know just has to what the Queen
but there are some remarkable defensive
resources here right like here you would
think that black is in trouble because
of the rooks e7i David Knight c8 works
and so on it so it's very much clear
that he had better defensive ideas and
what I spotted during the actual game
okay guys thanks for watching